yeah I competed in boxing judo wrestling
jujitsu MMA have a man yeah now what do
you think is the best martial art for
defending yourself against an untrained
opponent there's so many different
factors but let's say for instance okay
most fights I've seen are one-on-one
they're the fights we hear about are an
ass-whipping like seven people versus
three people and okay the more variables
you add in it gets very very difficult I
would say them the best fighting style
is using your brain and because less
voiding the fight well avoid in the
fight but I would say intelligent it's
just like investment now I know nothing
about investing which is why I don't do
it but um let's say for instance a
Warren Buffett is looking at a stock
page now I'm speculating because I don't
know mr. Buffett but I do have someone
who's standing up how the world works so
I would say that some days he looks at
the page it says haha there's a good
investment here and other days
regardless of his skill and investment
he says there's nothing to do the best
thing to do is wait but your Warren
Buffett tell me the best investment yeah
the best investment today still sucks
and I'm not going to make it talked to
me next week and I'll see what's out
there
so till next week we're gonna make we're
gonna we're going to invest some money
maybe and then you know he'll make the
read as he sees it so let's say for
instance you walk into a room and your
goal was to kill everyone in the room
and you are armed but you walk in to
50/50 Jitsu and you're going to shoot
everybody but for whatever reason it's
bringing your gun to the gym Tuesday and
everyone else is sitting there polishing
their fully-loaded again rounding the
chamber safety off weapons hot all that
good stuff and you see everyone else is
armed what do you do wait until
Wednesday
you come back in on Wednesday when no
one's armed then you shoot us all to be
great so it's that would being the best
tactical shooter you could be as ninja
as you want we're going to kill you
there's too many of us in too few of you
could you make it out of there and like
some sort of Boondock Saints awesome
luckiness and managed to get everybody
sure I wouldn't bet on it
that's like Floyd Mayweather against
three people I would bet on him sometime
seriously anybody that tells you
differently is never fought an untrained
person because regular people can't
fight for [ __ ] and the other thing is
they get scared so the one Floyd
literally cripples the first guy with a
right hand the other two guys unless
they're really seriously probably go
oh and then hesitate but they may not
but let's so if you think about it
though four people five people three
people ah let's say it's one on one but
Floyd's minding his own business against
snuck over the shoulder as he's sitting
there ordering a drink at a bar all
these different things factored in so I
would say that when it comes to the
physical expression of how to best
defend yourself the most important thing
is situational awareness and
understanding what's going on around you
because you could be the world's
greatest ninja warrior and still run
yourself into a lose-lose situation
could I knock out Floyd Mayweather yeah
sure I could if you let me hit him but I
don't think I would come within spitting
distance of him if he didn't want me to
I would have no teeth before I even
tried but if he sits there and lets you
hit him he is a man he is mortal so
basically under the right circumstances
anyone can win onto the wrong
circumstances anyone can lose so I would
say that understanding that is two step
one to being able to be an effective
effective strategist who can read a
situation you say should I fight this
one out should I not should I get out of
here should I fight for four seconds and
run for it and you know when you take
into account the physical expression of
everything and you want to let's say for
instance you know the most important
things for defending yourself in real
life I would say probably wrestling or
jiu-jitsu probably jiu-jitsu really in
my opinion but that's just perfect for
fighting I would say other things if I
want to be able to beat up more than one
person I know it implies that I can
wrestle or I can because regular people
can't wrestle for [ __ ] you will you
could pick him up and slam your head on
the ground or something horrible you
know but boxing would be nice as well
but let's say you're a great boxer and
someone tackles you could a regular
person tackle a good boxer yes alright
could a regular person sucker a good
jujitsu guide for sure but it also
really comes down to the to the mental
and everything like that but basically
if I had to pick one art and the
everyone knows nothing I would picture
issue but in my opinion jiu-jitsu at a
high level involves wrestling so just
like you said grappling is this bigger
thing that involves wrestling's you know
everything no doubt that's like you take
an Olympic level wrestler and you let
him lean on top of your inside control
it's not pleasant
you